[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
have a very exciting episode comin at ya
we're gonna be talking about force
bathing we have the founder of force
bathing Club joining us on the show
Julia Julia Pleven hey thanks for coming
out of the show really appreciate it
I've been having a lot of great
conversations with you and a lot of
other people about stewardship for Earth
and caring about what goes on with our
connection to earth and our connection
nature
I think force bathing's like totally
nature bathing in general is like at the
forefront of connecting people to earth
yeah and you're you're there two and a
half years into it and I want to talk
about that we'll get there but let's
talk about you first you know who are
you how did you end up becoming who you
are today yeah that is a big question
yeah I would say that I'm someone who's
always loved nature I grew up in the
suburbs of DC so it wasn't like living
you know in nature that connected really
went to college in New England to be in
nature surf rock climbed trail run
always on the go though and it wasn't
until I moved to New York City to grad
school and design that I started to
understand the mental health effects of
being connected to nature and then just
going to disconnected from nature and
really like why I love nature is that it
makes me feel good and when I'm
descending from nature I start to get
super anxious and stressed and a lot of
health issues like my own health issues
and I realize that basically every
health issue stems on some level from a
disconnection from nature including like
addiction and overconsumption and that
to me kind of pieced it all together
like in design
we have human Center design which is
kind of like been the the past 10-15
years has been like the how to design
things for human needs and I'm like and
then there's been design for
sustainability but it's been
disconnected I'm like actually if we're
designing for humans are not designing
also this like whole system's level for
the planet then we're not designing for
humans because we are nature and we need
to be connected to nature you know and
if it's not serving nature it's
ultimately not serving us either yes yes
so this is you start you started when
you started talking about this you you
were teaching me about how you you're
very confident that a lot of our our
addictions are over consumptions a lot
of the so called pathologies that we
have within society stem from our
disconnect nature so tell us about that
yeah so I in grad school went super deep
and stumbled into all of these terms
that were created to talk about the ways
that being disconnected from nature
makes us sick especially on a mental
like level which to me as someone who
has had anxiety for most of my life I
was like founded myself in all these
terms one that we talked about was Eco
anxiety which is just like anxiety over
the state of what's happening on the
planet and then the extreme of that is
ego paralysis which is like oh my god
these problems are so big and I am so
small that I can't do anything let's
break these down one at a time I have
them up here so Eco anxiety yeah okay
anxiety over what's happening on the
planet okay so this is is this stem from
a like we think you you feel maybe a
little bit of the the four stations and
the ocean acidification
great so you know we talked so anxiety
and stress are like such huge issues
right now alright and like but people
don't really realize that it comes like
that anxiety we feel
because the earth is it's like we feel
what the earth feels because we are the
earth so like you know we're feeling
yeah that's right absolutely we are one
with the planet so we feel the
acidification of the oceans we feel the
fish dying the coral reefs dying right
and so like the decrease in oxygen from
the DeForest station yeah exactly
and there's a whole like ecopsychology
eco therapy this idea that you know you
go to a therapist and you sit on a couch
and you like talk about your relations
with your parents and your friends but
you don't ever talk about your
leadership with the earth that's right
that's a really good point so that's
really interesting so psychologists
psychiatrists we rarely we rarely talk
even with our friends when we're hanging
out when do we ever talk about you know
how's your relationship with earth how
do you feel about nature right now yeah
when do we ask them right and how is
that affecting our psyche yeah so keep
keep teaching us yeah so that's so
that's ego anxiety so your paradigm
shift to have more conversations about
our relationship with nature I love that
yeah that's a really good because we
love asking questions so if we can ask
more questions in our day-to-day
interactions with other people and ask
them about how they feel currently about
the state of nature that's a really
great idea okay yeah okay and like just
knowing what its present in nature right
now you know so like not disconnecting
your personal experience and what the
earth is experiencing but realizing that
it's connected yeah yeah how do you
recommend prior to moving on how do you
recommend people get past the
the that there is a wall between me and
other like that that I am part of the
interconnectedness how do you recommend
people to so that's where for us mailing
comes out okay okay so loving towards it
okay perfect yeah so we're getting there
okay there's a whole host of these terms
and I like love learning about them we
can we can go through easy
yes I really want to keep going through
this okay go paralysis is like I'm so
overwhelmed about all of the stuff going
on that I just don't know what to do so
I'm gonna do nothing and yeah that's
almost as though when your to-do list is
so overwhelming that you're like I'm
just gonna you know watch a movie and go
to bed instead that's kind of what that
feels like
yeah when you look at Earth and you see
that it's okay yeah yeah um solastalgia
already in woodland yeah I just got more
on eco proud yes so so it's fascinating
that you bring these terms into our
nomenclature because these are these
seem like they're neologisms well so
list I'll just for sure neologism but
the these are so important that you
brought them into into life yeah yeah
and so there's there's all of these
terms which are so important because
they bring awareness to all of these
feelings that we're feeling that we
don't actually know it's like if you
learned the word like joy and you're
like oh my god that's an emotion I feel
yeah you know or like you learn sadness
like you learn the more that we can like
bring shine light on different emotions
or like it's like oh it it makes our
experience make more sense yes yes so
now we have a word to go along with the
feeling which is a feeling of in
sometimes this overwhelming feeling or
this anxious feeling about what's going
on on the planet okay and then I'll also
ask you about what is kind of the first
things we can do so as we go to nature
bathing Club then there's also other
things that we can
do to act to be activists in this yeah
okay so I would say the first step is
awareness like know that there's a
problem right and it's like if you don't
know there's anything wrong you can't do
it so these terms are really helpful in
that like bringing light through
problems to light yes yes
so Soulja solastalgia is a loss of
solace for a place you never left as it
has changed and like we were talking
about this we see this in San Francisco
people lamenting over the artists being
kicked out or all the techies coming in
or all these big buildings and the
city's changing but now we see it really
clearly on an environmental scale
California the forest you know being
fire like turn to ashes right now and
towns decimated you can see the
satellite imagery of places like Dai
Amazon rainforest just literally it
looks like a a worm weasel through like
a road and then it's just branches off
that road of just for the forest has
just been literally football field by
football field taken and driven back to
off that road yeah yeah it's insanity
yeah
okay so then soon and continue continue
on this because this is this is a
neologism this is definitely new so it's
like it's a researcher Glenn Albrecht in
Australia coined this term okay yeah but
yeah it was neat Glenn Albrecht yeah goe
and any money when Albrecht yeah to ends
I think on the clan but that should come
out yeah
interesting yeah there is Professor
sustainability of Murdoch University in
Western Australia retired in 2014 are
nary fell at the school of geosciences
love to meet this environmental
philosopher theoretical and applied
interest in relationship between
ecosystem and human health
he was pioneer the research domain
psycho terror attic interesting or earth
related mental health conditions
fascinating yeah Wow the concept of
solastalgia were the lived experience of
negative environmental change Wow feels
animal ethics and ethics of relocating
endangered species in the face of
climate change pressures whoa what an
interesting word though solastalgia and
then also psycho too rowdy yeah it's
like a three Attic whoa yeah yeah tarah
earth and psycho yeah
mental health yeah whoa yeah the way
your like your way your eyes like light
up about this like you know it expresses
your like deep yeah passion and care
about this it's it's been you know and
it's one of those things really like
I've been researching this for so long
and like and then it's like finally I'm
like there's someone who thinks this is
like worthy I'm like thank you because
I've been living in my own little world
you know these terms I always thought
were so fascinating and people were like
enough with your like weird words
already and now we're finally at the
believe it's like it is gonna hate
enough with your weird words like oh
these are very important yeah yeah yeah
like we were talking earlier about
coherence and resonance and stuff like
that they can sound like they're like
weird words but they're actually
extremely important words that will
likely take on a major role in society
once awakens yeah
yeah yeah yeah so you studied people
like Glenn for like - for a couple years
yeah yeah yeah and so I was in design
school though which is people like why
are you setting this in design school I
was on my own kind of like deep nature
connection exploration like in my own
little world in New York City and I
thought I was all alone in it and so I
like got deeper and realized that
there's a lot of people doing this work
but um Japan when were those first
forced bathing measurements of cortisol
levels in Japan yes so shinrin yoku
which means forest bathing literally
bathing in the forest atmosphere yeah
that was that word came about in
nineteen nineteen eighties and shinrin
yoku there it is yeah interesting and
that making in the forest atmosphere
shinrin yoku yeah oh so cool and they
did all of this research and it was
based on the fighting sides which is the
oils that the trees emit what are the
fightin sides by in size but insides how
do I spell that pH y EO n CI des ersten
yeah substance emitted by plants and
trees and generally means the aroma of
the forest fightin means plant and latin
inside means to exterminate so what's
crazy is this these oils breathing in
these oils has all of these it lowers
your increases your natural killer cells
so it lowers like you're like decreases
the cancer like it's preventive cancer
it has all these benefits you got yeah
what's interesting and this is like the
beautiful how systems and nature work is
that trees emit by insides as like to
wear it off insects yeah so the
protection trees protect themselves from
harmful insects in Germany so it's
protecting the trees but it's really
good for us
and it protects us like it's when we
take in fights in sides we also protect
ourselves from like you said these
cancer or these we decrease our stress
hormones yeah interesting
yeah phytoncide yes because we are
evolved to be in relation with nature
and trees so everything is like yeah
perfect
yes yes Wow there's such a distinct
difference between between you know like
there's like a hugely like distinct
difference between like these two like
these like images like this compared to
this is Muir Woods right just in our
North in our North Bay yeah and then
this is right so this is insane the
comparison between these two things like
I know
so shinrin yoku they now have like in
Japan these forest bathing stations
throughout the country and they have
it's part of their preventative health
care and since then since these research
on the fighting side sirs on all this
other research on the benefits of nature
including looking at images of nature is
actually you know like people who have
windows and hospitals that look out to
nature heal faster just having photos of
nature than studies will decrease your
stress why are we locked into the white
rooms like why don't we have the like
with the window in the hospital why
don't we have the a bunch of plants in
the in the as close as we can do in the
office buildings that we have and I
think that will come like as awareness
around just how much nature makes us
feel better and makes us healthier like
I can imagine bringing nature back into
the city isn't like there is a movement
of like going out to nature and there is
it I don't actually believe in going out
teacher because nature is all around us
our nature but you know there's being
like in remote places but then there's
also being in cities of when and I think
like bringing integrating that nature
back into the city is a huge it's where
we're gonna have to move you know it's a
huge opportunity you're you're familiar
with our ecology ecology combines
ecology with architecture Wow
yeah so the general ideas can what is
the future of architecture of
incorporating nature into what we build
yes as housing as offices as structures
as all this different type of stuff and
so this is a huge thing that I'm very
passionate about very excited about and
it kind of kind of you put it into two
interesting perspectives there's there's
going out to which I want to I want to
ask you about this but you know there's
going out to nature and then there is
bringing nature to the buildings that we
live and there's kind of us to set
there's two distinctly like different
movements you were teaching us that
there are right now there are locations
in Japan where they do actually like
specifically meant to take people out to
go in yeah yeah oh there's like little
bases all around the country and I had
the opportunity to go to a couple which
are really awesome and go on a forest
bathing with a guide in Japan let's see
how they do it which is you know it's a
practice that the term comes from Japan
but the practice of connecting to nature
is part of all original culture you know
like any traditional culture has their
practice of going back to nature out for
spiritual reasons you know and it's just
something that's like been lost over
over time and so it doesn't there's
elements of it that like the practice
itself doesn't come from Japan you know
they put a name to it but it's if
anything it ties back into if they're
like Shinto Buddhist tradition then
Japan is just so inherently like aware
of nature they don't actually even
have awareness of how interconnected
they are to nature do you think that
this is the right move to have the these
locations in the countries in like
Germany and in South Africa and Nigeria
and Brazil etc do you think that having
the sites near metropolis where people
can go once a week or to go - yeah this
is a good question so I think first to
me forest bathing is a way in it's a
process you know like how do you how do
we bring this into greater awareness and
I want to step back because first we
have all of these terms that you're
talking about okay let's go back - yeah
the terms it's a really important story
line because yes what happens is people
don't need okay so another one is
generational environmental amnesia which
is that people think the nature that
they grow up with is normal but really
it's being degraded over time and it
starts saying like me growing up in the
suburbs that that was normal but thirty
years ago that had been wild and the
other day I saw a kid walking around San
Francisco with a mask on because we're
currently dealing with all our fires and
it's become normalized it's become
normalized so he'll grow up thinking
that this is just like November it's
wildfire season and I'm actually heard
that it might not just be November you
know it's me more and more but um what
happens is we have all these ways that
nature makes that this disconnection
makes us anxious and stressed and sick
but how do you heal that and it's
actually grant Glenn Albrecht who coined
solastalgia who also occurring the term
soul athelia oh interesting so thelia
which means connecting going to nature
as a way to heal yourself your community
in the planet and when I heard that I
was like awesome and I really tried to
make the word soul affiliate happen I
was like I'm leading soul affiliate
groups and you know I'm like I don't
know it's like nothing to neologism yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it was like sounds
like a disease or something
yeah but then I came across the term
forest bathing and I was like that
sounds cool
yes so that's why I started it called it
the forest bathing Club yep and but
really it is a practice of coming
together and going to nature as and it's
about like getting out of your head
dropping into your heart awakening your
senses different practices that you can
go and do or different invitations of
ways to connect and then coming back and
integrating in circle and it's really
important that you have that like go out
and can come back because it starts to
build this container and he's like you
see something that I don't see and it
just like we all create this deep
experience together
yeah and it's amazing because you start
you go out as a way of healing and you
know because of the science but then
once you're there you realize there's so
much more that's going on and to me
there's like an inherently spiritual
element to it of you get whatever
message you're meant to at that time
from nature and I have one invitation
where I like I have a story that I can
talk to treif and I go to a tree and
I'll ask it a question of like something
I'm dealing with in my life
like I had this problem where I have a
decision what should I do and I get some
kind of knowing from a higher place yak
and when I first started telling about
the people I was like they're gonna
think I'm crazy but then I did it again
and again and everyone got a message
back you know and so like it quickly
becomes like you go out because of the
health benefits but you quickly get
these like this heightened you know
spiritual or like this higher place that
then helps you navigate your life yeah
yes the way that you're describing it is
so it's it's relatable because I think
and I feel that when the first instances
of us leaving the metropoliz area and
going to your woods or Stinson Beach or
wherever we're going that we we finally
get to feel the feelings of Earth that
are not when we are behind a computer
and we're kind of locked into buildings
versus being out on a beach or out
amongst trees because then when you when
you see the birds that are flying and
when you see the squirrels that are
running across the tree branches and
when you smell the the fight fight fight
fight on fight inside uh-huh oh my gosh
what a cool word when that when that
happens it that's that's that's an
awareness shift totally and that's the
connection in nature and a lot of things
happen like you start to realize that
you're really small you know ego gets
dwarfed yeah and you start like there's
all these studies when I favorite ones
is that people looking up at a tree for
one minute experience a greater sense of
awe just one minute I'm looking at a
tree in you like an eyes so port related
to all these other positive you know
things of like collaboration and I went
to Humboldt last year they had the big
Sequoia is up there yeah and it was
fascinating yeah I felt it
it was beautiful I felt small because
there are huge trees yeah so I I just
sorry thank you
yeah Ron Ronnie when you when you speak
like that on the show makes me wanna you
know give you that a big hug yes yeah
don't touch me
Rod's usually the no but last year
around this time I was like I mentioned
though I've never seen the trees that
large ever in my life so I was so what
else is beautiful warm he is even just
talking about it
so what's amazing about nature is those
people having me like meditation not for
me
ayahuasca not for me all these things
but no one says nature not for me is
it's like it's it's biophilia we are
like we are inherently attracted to
nature like that's a really good one
we're part of it yeah biophilia and the
it's you bring up this great point which
is we get all these not for me is the
meditation not for me psychedelics not
for me nature uh well okay fine like
okay I look sure I'll go out to the
beach sure I'll go I'll go out to the
forest like that and people have their
own practices of doing it you know but
there's always people it's I've never
met a human who like I mean maybe there
actually there is instance of the people
who grow up in cities or who have been
conditioned that nature is dangerous
that's right yeah so sad if you grew up
in the metropolis and they never
actually saw the Milky Way thing kid
they never saw the galaxy yes they never
went out to pitch darkness away from the
light pollution to be able to look up
they seemed like five stars yeah and
then you know what happens then is you
don't you don't have that appreciation
like growing up then it's really hard to
come into as an adult yes yeah I and you
know I have I had this I have a I had
this hypothesis written here just right
under you know it's this is you know
this is it's right here just one third
of all engineers in the Bay Area haven't
been to put the Pacific Ocean and now
you can just broaden that and say
techies I don't know if that's true or
not that's that's a hypothesis yeah but
I think if we took a poll of all the
techies that have moved to the Bay Area
I'd be curious
to see how many of them haven't been to
the Pacific Ocean yet totally and this
is part of my saying it's like with all
of the knowledge I have around benefits
of being in nature and like why don't I
live in the middle of a forest why am I
in San Francisco and I sort of I feel
that it's part of my Dharma to bring
nature and the benefits of it to Silicon
Valley to the techies the people who are
creating our future yes because if we
are able to get them tapped and and
connected then you know technology is a
reflection of our consciousness that's
right so if we get them excited - nature
of consciousness and they'll create
things that you know are aligned with
the planet and that's what we really
need right now I love you Julia so much
your your mission is extremely important
your your and you know you're speaking
about a civilizational level you're not
like hey I'm gonna go take you know one
person out you're like no I'm gonna take
Silicon Valley oh yes I'm gonna take
Shenzhen and Beijing I'm gonna take the
world out to the these hubs that are
building the future they need to go out
and into nature because it's gonna be a
reflection of what they make us
technology that's that's really
important and that's how we can solve
some of the ethical and moral quandary
that we face there's like you know what
would nature do like that's kind of how
I always think about things now it's
like what is what is the living system
like what is the example from nature and
this is a system that has been working
for billions of years and we have been
this like blip on the planet we have
everything to learn from the way that
nature does things and that's where like
biomimicry comes in that's where like
regenerative comes in that's where yet
this institute for earth-based inquiry
that I've been building as part of like
a you know a forest bathing is this
recreational two-and-a-half hour
experience I believe it's
transformational within and it's like
what next yes which we wanted to talk
about this too is like how do you get to
the action item from the you feel can
feel anxiety you go for space then what
do I do after that
to help be a part of the solution
totally and then you know first you
bring you start to bring that and
integrate it back into your life so
whatever lessons you get from nature you
bring in you can also physically bring
it in like we're talking about having
plants having little stones things that
remind you of like a call like an
instant forest bath you know you're like
okay like you know there's bigger
systems out there connected to something
larger and then there's like principles
that you start to learn from how nature
works and that is where there's so much
exciting things to learn out like how
fractals and the cycles of nature you
know and even using that like in our
workflow how can we tap into seasonality
in work like we you know a tree isn't
bearing fruit all year round it's only
in the fall after going through in a
whole process there's a lot of like time
we're in the winter where you're more
dormant and looks like there's not much
going on there's a lot happening beneath
the surface like starting to learn from
all of these systems yeah yes we were we
we had started talking about the way
that for some reason we were
interestingly talking about
procrastination as well early yeah we
were wondering do do like trees
procrastinate well I'm pretty sure and
we'd have to research this more but I'm
pretty sure when a tree has a surplus of
co2 that it gives the co2 to the trees
that don't that aren't unable to get it
from the tops of the of the of the
atmosphere that they're not actually
touching that they're not hitting yeah
and so and I believe that it's a root
system it's a root system connection
from tree to tree and that I don't think
it like [ __ ] it doesn't definitely
doesn't hoard it we've seen that because
we've made a radioactive isotope of
carbon and then followed it and that's
how we learned that about the tree
systems talking underneath the roots but
you know we were also talking about
squirrels and yeah squirrels don't very
so many of they're not
and acorns and then they only recover we
learned 74% right right and we were
saying how like silly squirrels they
don't have very they're not very smart
they lose a lot of their eight coins and
I'm like oh wait a second why and then I
realized that that's actually they're
planting trees and it's like this
perfectly designed system like you know
it's amazing
and then also trees need a trigger so
like an environmental trigger like a
fire will cause a tree to release air
plants release seeds so when there's
stress you know or like when a trees had
a really hard winter it'll like have
extra fruit so it like it's like these
are like a when it's dying it'll release
everything it has and it's like this
impulse just like give and to continue
life and that like that is the impulse
we all have is like to keep life going
yeah what's oh where where are you now
with forest bathing Club how far along
how many of these two-and-a-half-hour
have you done now I've done a lot I
probably close to a hundred that I've
led yeah and whereabouts so a lot in the
city and that was part of like in the
Presidio and Sutro Forest lands then and
that was part of it like yes we can go
to muir woods yes you know we have
amazing nature right here but we don't
have to leave to Golden Gate Park and
yeah like you said for Funston Presidio
yeah and I was for a while leading
Airbnb experiences and you know through
that like be a good group of VCS would
come on the forest path and oh you'd be
like hey guys guess what they yeah it's
like they loved it
and then I took a lot of this year I'm
like owned like deep connection writing
a book on this mm-hmm
upcoming book very excited yeah the
healing magic of forest bathing yeah
yeah yeah ooh that's gonna be super fun
because you you're you're writing about
a lot of things that we're talking about
yeah yeah but so I was living super into
the nature and not really doing many of
these forest baths and then now I'm like
integrating it all back in but also
wondering it's like doesn't need to be
you know this is when you're building
community you're building a culture so
like does it need to be like how often
do you do this out like how do you do it
what are the rituals and then again you
look to nature you look to ancient
traditions that have this you know and
it's like you know like the moon cycle
do you do it every new moon or full moon
you know like different heights of the
year summer solstice winter you know
yeah it's important it's important yeah
it was times mm-hmm solstice you imagine
their faces even every new moon and full
moon even every time that happens that's
that that'd be great that's twice every
28 days yeah that's great and it starts
to tap you into these natural rhythms
yeah that's great and that's only once
every two weeks that's really not that
often yeah yeah so so how many people
were going on these like 10 20 up to 20
to limit it to 20 because otherwise then
you feel like you're in a crowd but
totally there's something really
powerful about doing it in these groups
yeah yeah when's the next one oh the
next one I'm actually going to do an
impromptu one on this Sunday after
Thanksgiving and I've been thinking
about what to do all these fires so I
think it's it's going to be don't like
free forest bath but with a suggested
donation to fire relief yeah yeah
college that we'll figure out which one
or it would be eventually good to go
near the ocean because it's
has been it's been cleaned out yeah yeah
or cycles yeah and even you know to be
present with what's going on right so
it's like I was supposed to have a
awesome event this last weekend in Ohio
at eco topia and we invented out all of
the hot springs our time with yoga and
CBD and forest bathing and all these
people signed up but then the fires came
and I was like well can we still get
there should we cancel it and I was like
yes not only because I don't want to be
sending people that way and people are
fleeing their homes and being evacuates
doesn't seem right but also because it's
not the time and a lot of this is just
being present with what's actually
happening and you know so like there is
a time to heal with nature but there's
also time to grieve and so you know and
so yeah driving towards the direction
that everybody's driving away just to go
and bathe there y-yeah yeah there's this
crazy this happening yeah I loved I
loved the idea of connecting you to
Murray Hillary who does mine travel we
had him on the show as well as he does a
lot of silent hikes crow people play
piano while people are wearing and
they're working and so that would be an
interesting synergy he also does in
impulse people wear wet suits and you
lay down in a in a pool and then there's
underwater speakers that play that
vibrations feels amazing so I think you
two would be very cool a good partner I
talked about experience design there
like as a designer I love to design
experience people but I'm like really
nature is the ultimate designer yeah and
we are just like co-creating with nature
or being a vessel you know or and that's
what I say when you go out into the
forest like nature is the healer nature
is the teacher just opening the gate you
know just holding the space for everyone
to have their own connection to nature
and I think also on a healing level like
I believe that the best healers enable
people to heal themselves yes and nature
is the ultimate healer so like by
connecting people to nature have their
own connection they foster they're able
then take their own healing into their
own hands yeah yeah the best yet
teachers are they are the ones that
enable you to yourself be able to
achieve what you set out to do exactly
Wow
thank you Ron No
yeah Ron you ever thought you know we'd
have to tell the guests about that I
don't think sometimes you know yeah yeah
yeah
just 15 minutes you okay Julie I'm good
I'm good so so this is somatic programs
for accelerating connections is this
something that you want to talk about
space because I thought this was
interesting yeah yeah so you know it's
started by wanting to bring forest
bathing more into startup world into
Silicon Valley into corporations and
what is the best way to do that yeah
you're like and I actually got some
feedback again I like forest bathing is
a great term for individuals were
consumed you know but does it work for
how do you get people like in the office
Vick we need this it's a jump to be like
we need forest bathing but yes we need
space somatic programs for excellent
connection to earth you know it just
it's just changing the term and changing
the offering slightly to be more aligned
with what people in who are building
tech might be looking for what does this
have to do their bottom line right you
know it's like the same thing but just
packaged in a way that might be that is
meant to be more like yeah this may be a
fascinating measurement to do with with
levels of anxiety stress depression also
levels of of
empathy or altruism so pre and post
totally pre and post nature bathing
horse bathing yeah and so then also then
somehow measure a productivity as well
yeah they have done all these studies
and nature does is proven to increase
all of these things yes correct
that's the those are the studies with
Japan those have been going on for a
while but then I want to know even more
so with productivity has that been a has
that been studied I guess I don't know
about productivity but all was study
because you know they look yeah even a
minute gets ah and AH leads to things
like empathy and altruism yeah but I'd
be very interested in productivity
because then you could really get it to
the execs and say that you know this is
actually increasing productivity yeah
and to me I'm like well what does
productivity actually mean like
productive doing what yeah and if it's
like not reaching these planetary goals
and like is it even productive yeah it
isn't even productive exactly yeah we're
productively building advertising yeah
right that distracts you from your goals
like no that's not productive
exactly yeah yeah but I do believe as I
say like it magically will reprioritize
you so you'll start to know what your
priorities are
and that a lot of us like the blockage
to productivity is like not knowing what
your priorities are and once you're in
nature and just get a lot more clear all
that mess in your head is gone and
you're able to totally focus on what
you're meant to be focusing on part of
that to me has so much to do so much
similarity with meditation and
psychedelics as well yeah it the jumble
that's in our minds from waking up every
day and going to sleep the data sleep
did it and so when you take a big long
break from it you're able to
connect more to what is essentially
important to you what are your what is
your essence and are you act are those
meetings about meetings actually in the
board it was so crazy after living in
since and Beach and like I really didn't
see many people I got slick and this
like writer's little cabin and it's
taught disconnect from a lot of society
a lot of like I saw my parents and like
to friends and then I came into the city
and I had a meeting downtown and I was
just like watching with like wow all
these people like it was just amazing
they like go and they had their lunch
and they like get into the elevator and
they press a button and then get to the
floor and it's like these little robots
I don't think we're how does everyone
know where to go like they're all just
like kind of programs I'm following the
algorithms can it can be nuts yeah show
up at show up at 8:00 take lunch at 12
walk to a corner to get food back with
food to desk work until 5:00 go home
yeah like these algorithms are in Sandy
in many ways insanity
it totally it's and it's like then a lot
of this to me like we're going to nature
is also reconnecting to your so its
outer nature and then it's your inner
nature and like who are you like who are
you what is your actual nature and that
is to me like a life on discovery
process and what you start to realize
you're like do I actually want to eat at
like eight noon in six yeah you know
yeah do I want to follow the the
cultural programming that I may not
actually that is not actually me right
you bring you bring up a very
interesting point I like I've started to
call it maybe civilization design or
planetary architecture right yeah and
you seem to be very awakened to what is
what was it again it was it was uh it
was it was iko iko iko iko anxiety a bit
of that a bit of like a bit of
solastalgia cedrus just this you you can
you see it architected in a way that can
you see a more beautiful architecture
yeah and I do too in many ways yeah and
okay so now let's let's talk about the
action okay okay so how do we architect
that yeah yeah integrated in and that I
think a lot of it is there's a guy Ron
Finley who talks he does this these
gardens in LA and they're like talks
about the garden that we need to be
gardening it's a garden between our two
eyes ooh and I think that is a lot of it
it's like up leveling our consciousness
and then it then it's like once that set
in motion then everything else so we set
in motion because I do believe that we
are all on this planet at this time for
a purpose that you know it's like things
come up from the earth at certain time
there's certain things like there's all
of these invasive species that are
actually medicine right now and the
register like they're teaching us about
no like physically much so like as
there's all these like stomach issues
you know like IBS plate it's there's
there's herbs that are popping up that
are like that heal that feel bad and
they're invasive but they're actually
the earth is like hey I'm giving you
this medicine right now and and maybe
these things like IBS and stuff are are
a learning experience for us I like to
sometimes think of some of the darkness
on the planet as a learning experience
totally yeah yeah and I think that's
exactly what happens is like it's meant
for us to remember that for us to
remember that's a good way to put it
okay so it's a beach so if if we focus
between our two eyes if we focus on the
if we focus on - there you go focus on
our mind and our soul our body if we
focus on this and do leveling this up
overtime continuously increasing our
awareness our connection to nature then
the end results will come right so okay
so yes and what I believe is like when
we literally physically have our feet in
their earth our hands in the dirt yes we
start to that just hard to happen
naturally like yeah we can go out on all
these crazy trips and all these whatever
but you can also just spend a lot of
time in nature and that'll start to
happen but what I believe is that this
purpose you know like just as these
plants of purpose were popping up we
have a purpose or being here and it
literally it comes from the earth and it
rises up through our body and our head
is the last thing to know so by being in
nature we are able to get clear on what
we're meant to do and what I meant to do
on this planet is different from what
you're meant to do like it's all on
servers of something greater than
ourselves it's all in service of the
greatest good and like life continuing
but it's going to be different for each
we're talk about like each person has
their own place their their own unique
purpose that none of us have so like me
telling you how to live isn't right
either because it's like you're gonna
have your own right way to do it and
it's just about connecting yourself so
that you can figure that out and once we
are all like someone is gonna be an
amazing scientist is gonna solve like
you know climate change someone else is
going to be able to solve this someone
else a bug yeah I just a lot of what you
say about putting your hands and your
feet into the actual sand or dirt that
that reminds me of the childlike spirit
that when you come back to that
childhood mentality being able to to
just be free and play that that can
bring you into a closer tie
oh my god why have we been like
conditions that play is not productive
or like play is bad and like work is
supposed to be serious well cuz there's
a dark villain that doesn't want us to
remember these things and do these
things it says something among us that
just wants to take complete control
wants to think it's God wants us to mind
our business pay our taxes and just go
along to get along
that's why what do you think about the
dark villain do you what are your
thoughts about our feelings about that
like the did what is the darkness yeah
oh man I I really try not to spend too
much time that's a great answer because
you're right I can't Rob loves feeling
yeah but no you've been spent like III
it doesn't come very easy for me because
it knows my name it has my numbers so I
can't easily dismiss it but for anybody
that's what what you're doing Julia you
know stay the course keep your eye on
the prize and you are you are leaving
whatever doc villain that is among us in
the dust so it seems very interest to
not even acknowledge it that's right
yeah love it I love it beautiful good
answer so and briefly back to children
and play yes work where you were going
yeah because ultimately like you know we
talked about we're here it's love and
play we're here to be wild tenders of
the earth and to love and play and
that's basically what it comes down to
and I want to make sure we talk about
wild tenders on the way out because you
taught me about wild tenders and I was
like oh my god that's like what I've
been thinking about with being a the
pinnacle of a potential civilization
what what would it look like we were at
the pinnacle of what a civilization
looks like and I think that means like
perfect harmonic stewardship with the
planet and that's what you were teaching
you about wild tenders which is Native
American yes so it's this concept you
know we have this idea of nature as
being like hands off Leave No Trace it's
a museum that we just said like go to
enjoy but actually
especially in California and the Native
Americans were very hands-on with nature
and you co you what's the tribe maybe
that was I'm not oh oh I've never been
down the tribe name is the it's the
Yurok tribe yeah but yeah there's I mean
throughout California but in the Klamath
up and clams me rock yeah but like you
know here we have the me walk and we
walk so they are involved in nature but
involved in like you know planting wild
tent like planting seeds pruning leaves
and like part of the ecosystem but
serving it in a way that's beneficial
and it's kind of like the squirrel it's
like part of the ecosystem leap
forgetting their acorns in a way that's
beneficial because it then grows trees
yeah and that's what we are our best use
of being here is to be wild tender so
not like trying to control but just
trying to serve in a way that's like
serve the stewardship yeah and then
serve the sole as well yeah yeah you
were jumping me into very interesting
conversation before this about
simulation theory because the show is
called simulation we love asking people
about if we're in a simulation yeah what
do you think this day answer to that you
know I I was just saying I read this
book how to break loose from the money
game and I don't it's a cool story that
it sent everything's a simulation that
were just like it's a movie and it's
powered by you know pattern and power
and we can change our patterns and
change the simulation hmm
I just heard this book I haven't seen
the results yet in terms of breaking
loose from the money game but but it is
a kind of funny thing like we're on our
way like certain ladies like certain
stereotypes happen where you're like
that is a perfect character of course
like that character is
that way it's like two like things that
happen I like eerily like simulated yeah
yeah yeah so yeah jury's out but I'm not
I'm not convinced that we're not yeah
all right what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world most
beautiful thing in the world is Wow
I think its flow
the flow and like you know we talk a lot
in Silicon Valley like flow state that
it uh but like actually being in the
flow like in the ocean you know and I
love to surf and everything every
metaphor of life comes from that like
just like the ego death again and again
as you're surfing and catching the wave
and staying on the wave and you know and
like that feeling of being in flow on
the ground to and seeing flow and seeing
that like that is the animator of all of
life wow that's a great answer being
flow
that money that might be another
interesting way to say that is like
meaningful engagement I found that to be
an interesting one
Jordan Peterson Tommy about that and I
like that flow and meaningful engagement
it's like the it's like the deepest of
cognitive instincts intuition and you
know this gets into like that feminine
knowing to like just that intuitive
sense and I it isn't a mistake that all
a lot of what we learn from nature is
also we learned from salmon intelligence
because that is nature yeah you know
it's these it's collaboration it's
following your intuition it's yeah
empathy yes stewardship seeing you were
also teaching us about seeing earth
through the lens seeing seeing seeing
reality through the lens of Earth yeah
when you see reality through the lens of
Earth you can feel better for Earth and
for the systems on the planet and how to
be a proper steward and care about each
other as humans yeah it's really a holy
cow this is such a pleasure I feel so so
grateful that you joined us on the show
thank you thank you thank you for
uplifting the powerful women in your
world
I love the powerful roles so so much and
there's we're gonna build together we're
gonna co-create it's gonna be beautiful
yeah thank you yeah force bathing is
super exciting go check it out force
bathing got club the links in the bio
everyone check it out check it out go
and lead forest bathing and nature
bathing yourself go and lead to be a
leader in your community and take people
out of the cubicles and corporate
offices and into nature and watch what
happens as you come back go with your
families go with your friends go and do
that everyone look out for Julia's book
when's it coming out March fit
March vid 2019
look out look out thanks everyone for
tuning in leave us your thoughts in the
comments below we'd love to hear from
you we'd love to hear what your thoughts
are on this
Thank You Ron for producing and
directing much love to you and join us
join us in the movement to rebirth the
public intellectual we have lots of
interviews across the world that we're
being invited to do with prominent
figures and we need your help to get
there join us on patreon join us on
cryptocurrency links are below thank you
very much for tuning in everyone much
love and we'll see you soon
you